jay-z is a business mogul record
executive
rapper and most importantly one proud
dad
baby i paint the sky blue my greatest
creation was you
the rapper opens up about his parenting
style in a rare interview with the
sunday times
sharing that the most important thing is
to show them love
he explains quote feeling loved is the
most important thing a child needs you
know
not here's this business that i'm going
to hand over to you that i'm creating
for you
the most amazing feeling i feel worse
can't describe it
for real jay who shares three kids with
wife beyonce
nine-year-old blue ivy and
three-year-old twins roomie and sir
reflects on his legacy as an entertainer
and insists he'll never push his kids to
follow in his footsteps
he says what if my child doesn't want to
be in music or sports
i have no idea right but as long as your
child feels supported and feels loved
i think anything is possible everything
that i pray for
god's gift i wish i would have prayed
more amid the pandemic
jay says he and wife beyonce have put
extra attention on their family
ensuring they provide a loving
environment and
are attentive to who they want to be he
adds
it's easy for us as human beings to want
our children to do certain things
but we have no idea we're just guides
is this the biggest thing you've ever
done becoming a mom this is my
greatest accomplishment and i am the
happiest i've ever been
and i feel the most empowered it just
makes me
feel so lucky to be a woman what's in
store for roomie and sir may still be up
in the air but when it comes to blue
it seems the talented youngster is fated
for a career
in hollywood
[Music]
that's blue singing brown skin girl a
song on her mom's visual album
black is king the collaboration earned
blue a b-e-t
award in naacp award and her very first
grammy
i never tried it for anybody else
singing and when you're beyonce and
jay-z's daughter you live
life to the fullest and celebrate by
turning grammy gold
into a sippy cup
[Music]
this makes me proud as a grammy winner
at 9 years old
blue is already on the fast track to
success
a precedent set by her mom who achieved
a milestone at the 2021 grammy awards
earning the most wins ever after nabbing
a trophy for
savage remix with fellow houston native
megan the stallion
who praised beyonce's big honor while
speaking with e.t
beyonce is a treasure to everybody in
houston
pretty sure to everybody in the world
but specifically from where we're from
we just love
absolutely love beyonce she set a record
tonight how important was that too
it's very important uh as just a black
woman entertainer
uh black women in general we're here
we're here to stay we're here to take
over we've been doing that but
like just shout out to beyonce for
making her story tonight